Welcome to the debate.
Imagine an entire society, structuring its laws, its daily rhythms, its marriages, and really its very understanding of the divine around a dazzling, priceless jewel.
Sounds beautiful.
It does, yeah.
They build these massive protective vaults for it.
Scholars dedicate their entire lives to describing its facets.
and generations base their survival on its perceived value.
Only to discover, centuries later, that what they have been so fiercely guarding is, well, it's nothing more than expertly polished glass.
Oh, that is a...
Devastating realization.
Devastating.
And today we are opening the pages of a profound text that forces us to confront this exact scenario, The Master and the Disciple by Jafar Ibn Mansour.
Our discourse focuses on a really pivotal exchange where a young teacher accepts a very gracious image from his opponent that wisdom is like jewels sparkling in the sunlight.
But
The young teacher then names a breaking condition that completely dissolves his opponent's entire religious framework.
He says real jewels can only be told from forged glass by the truest sayers.
And because of this profound necessity, he establishes our core thesis for today.
A religion grounded only in transmitted reports is not religion.
Well, I come at it from a different way because I think we have to recognize the immense
practical weight behind the opposing view here.
the opponent in this text, the visiting scholar, he is not just a straw man.
He is the greatest debater of his school.
And he is defending the absolute reality of what a community must do after revelation has ended.
The prophets are gone.
The direct line to the heavens is essentially closed.
And the visiting scholar represents the view that religion, practically speaking, equates to the sharia, the accumulated commands, prohibitions, and traditions handed down through reliable transmitted reports.
Inherited practice.
Exactly.
It is a system built on meticulous historical preservation.
You gather the reports of what was said and done, you verify the trustworthy nature of the people passing down those reports, and you build a logical, evidence-based framework for living.
That is the sunlight in his analogy.
if a teaching shines in the sunlight of public scholarly consensus, it has worth.
It allows a society to function across centuries without, without fracturing into private, unverifiable mysticism.
And, I mean, that defense of preservation is exactly why the visiting scholar is such a formidable opponent.
I see why that framework feels robust to him, but
Let me give you a different perspective on that sunlight and explain why the young teacher refuses to let public consensus serve as the ultimate judge.
Go ahead.
He accepts the jewel image, but he points out a fatal flaw in the mechanism of verification itself.
The sunlight of public opinion, or even intense scholarly consensus, is entirely superficial.
Sunlight can make a piece of forged glass sparkle just as brilliantly as a true diamond.
Because the light is hitting the surface.
Just the surface.
If the community holding the jewel cannot independently verify its internal composition, their consensus means absolutely nothing.
The stakes here are existential.
I mean, an entire community might be holding forged glass, believing it to be divine instruction simply because their jewels never reach the true assayers.
But, and who exactly are these assayers?
Because the visiting scholar is asking the hardest, most necessary question here.
It is very easy to speak of essayers in theory, but in the practical world, revelation has concluded the chain through which divine knowledge descended is no longer physically walking among us.
If the prophets are gone, transmitted texts are what we possess.
The young teacher argues that the assayers are the specific figures who receive divine knowledge from the heavens, those whose exclusive trade is the knowledge of these specific, divine gems.
Without them, relying solely on inherited texts creates an immediate catastrophic crisis.
And he pushes the debate out of the abstract and into the brutal reality of relying only on reports by bringing up a working example.
Which is.
The moon citing controversy.
Yes.
This is the perfect test case for the visiting scholar system.
You have communities attempting to navigate the divine calendar using only transmitted hadith.
And what is the result?
You have communities that end up eating on the first day of Ramadan, which is strictly forbidden.
Yeah.
And you have neighboring communities fasting on the day of Eid, which is also strictly forbidden.
They do this because the texts regarding how to track the calendar flat out contradict one another.
The saying about sighting the moon has literally become a saying about fighting over it.
Sect against sect, feast against fast.
They are finding paralyzing contradictions in the very texts they claim as their bedrock.
Replacing one chain of reports with a smaller one?
The texts are what we have, and moon sighting is the established method.
Yes, there is friction.
Human error in observing the sky is inevitable.
people look for the physical moon, some see it, some are obscured by clouds, some miscalculate the horizon.
I hear you, but that is an administrative challenge.
It is a practical difficulty in applying the law.
It does not mean the underlying foundation of relying on reports is bankrupt.
The community is doing its absolute best with the method it was explicitly given in the inherited reports.
It is absolutely not a mere administrative challenge.
The young teacher demonstrates that the chaos is not born from cloudy skies.
It is born from the community losing the symbol and completely collapsing it into a literal physical instruction.
What do you mean?
He recovers the true meaning of the phrase Follow the moon, which was given by the Messenger, peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family.
Read with the communities established symbols in hand.
This instruction was never a piece of astronomy.
It was the explicit designation of a successor.
Wait.
Before we move further, let's unpack the mechanics of that symbolism.
Because for a listener, taking a very straightforward command about a calendar and turning it into a command about political and spiritual leadership is a massive shift in reading.
How does the young teacher justify that leap?
He justifies it through the established cosmological architecture of the tradition.
Let's look at the second major analogy of this text.
The sun is the established symbol of the speaker prophet, the one who brings the revelation directly.
The source of the light.
Yes, the sun generates the light.
The moon, conversely, is the established symbol of the trustee, the one to whom authority is left after the Speaker Prophet departs.
Think about how a moon works mechanically in the sky.
It has no light of its own.
It reflects the light of the absent sun into the darkness of the night.
Oh, I see.
So, when the Speaker Prophet is gone, the world enters a period of darkness.
The instruction was not to stare at the sky.
The formula meant, in all matters of your life, follow the commander of the faithful.
Peace be upon him.
It was a comprehensive directive.
It wasn't limited to a single visible disc in the sky during one month of the year.
I don't buy that.
Yet reading the Mu saying as coded designation sounds like meeting read in after the fact.
That sounds like wordplay.
Who decides which symbol fits which figure?
Why should the visiting scholar, or anyone for that matter, accept that a command his community has taken literally for generations is actually an allegorical designation of authority?
Because the literal reading puts the community in direct, irreconcilable contradiction with the Quran's own witness.
How so?
The young teacher points directly to the book to resolve this, completely stripping away any accusation of mere wordplay.
In chapter 2, verses 183 to 184, the period of fasting is clearly defined as a fixed number of days, counted days.
Furthermore, the book testifies repeatedly that the heavenly bodies operate on precisely calculated pads that never ever deviate.
Okay.
In chapter 55, it states that the sun and the moon are reckoned by precise calculation.
Chapter 6 states, he has made the sun and the moon for the reckoning of time.
And chapter 36 states that for the moon, phases are ordained.
We have a unified witness to a single fact.
The physical moon follows a precise, calculable path.
Yes.
What never deviates can be calculated mathematically.
And what can be calculated cannot possibly be the object of a siding controversy where calculation is forbidden.
The confusion is not in the source.
The confusion is what the community did to the source when they collapsed the living trustee into a literal lunar argument.
A religion grounded only in transmitted reports is not religion.
That is, that is a fascinating reconstruction.
You are saying the source itself describes a.
universally calculable universe.
Exactly.
Therefore, interpreting the inherited report in a way that forbids calculation demands fallible human eyesight and results in communities violating sacred days.
It creates a massive theological contradiction.
Precisely.
If the book says the universe is calculable and your transmitted report says you must rely on a sighting method that actively results in fighting and sinning, the foundation of your system is cracked.
You are holding forged glass.
Okay, I hear the argument regarding the calendar.
And the recovery of the moon as the symbol for the trustee makes profound structural sense.
But let me press the young teacher on behalf of the visiting scholar here.
Please do.
Let's assume they misunderstood the calendar.
A calendar dispute is just one specific category of law.
The visiting scholar's defense of Sharia is that it governs the entirety of human relations, property, commerce, criminal justice, marriage.
Even if they lost the symbol of the moon, they still have a vast, deeply functional system of inherited reports that tells a society how to navigate daily life.
You cannot just dismiss the whole structure because of an astronomical dispute.
But the structure is not deeply functional.
That's the problem.
It is broken at the most intimate levels of daily life.
And the young teacher moves from the cosmic scale of the calendar to the practical devastation of corrupted Shriya by using a very human case.
He brings up a divorce case from the source.
Okay, what happens in the case?
A man divorces his wife once and then he breaks an oath.
He is terrified.
He goes to the scholars, the very people holding and interpreting these inherited reports, to find out his marital status.
Does breaking the oath finalize the divorce?
A very standard legal question.
Exactly.
And because the inherited reports contradict each other, the scholars cannot give him an answer.
They tell him that some reports say she is divorced, and some reports say she is not, and he should simply act according to whichever he likes.
Wait, they tell him to just choose his preference?
Yes.
Think about the psychological paralysis of that moment.
He is left completely stranded in his own home.
He does not know if looking at his wife is permitted or forbidden.
He does not know if staying in his house is a sin.
A religion that cannot answer a fundamental question about human relationships is not a religion, it is a chaotic market of reports.
Is that how wise judgment should operate in a divine system?
Is that what the visiting scholar calls a functional foundation?
I hate to admit it, but that divorce case exposes a fatal flaw.
I want to defend the system of inherited reports as a practical necessity for survival.
But if a man cannot even get a straight answer on whether he is married or divorced, the system is fundamentally broken.
Yeah.
It is one thing to argue about the sky.
It is another to leave a man paralyzed in his own living room, terrified of committing a sin because the text just cancel each other out.
And the visiting scholar is forced into a corner here.
He absorbs this case study.
He sees the paralysis.
And because he is intellectually honest, he officially concedes the point.
He admits it plainly.
Sharia in this form has been corrupted and rendered ineffectual.
The contradictory texts leave a person paralyzed, and the community is clinging only to the name of religion.
That concession is monumental.
It is the turning point of their entire discourse.
The greatest debater of the opposing school admits his jewel is glass.
It is monumental, but it immediately forces a much deeper crisis.
Having conceded, the visiting scholar must press the young teacher.
He says essentially,
Fine.
If our Sharia is corrupted, then what is the state of religion in your opinion?
How is this different from any school claiming its readers alone see the meaning?
A fair question.
The visiting scholar has just watched his core equivalents dissolve.
He believed religion equaled Sharia.
He admits the Sharia he holds is corrupted, therefore he is holding absolutely nothing.
If you take away the inherited reports, what is left?
Well, because he is holding nothing, the young teacher can now build something entirely new in its place.
He completely dissolves the religion equals Sharia equivalence.
And in its place, he lays out the third great analogy of this text.
a unified 7-image description of what true religion actually is.
Okay, let's go through these.
He tells the visiting scholar that true religion is the veil strengthened against those who sow corruption, its gates opened only to those seeking truth.
Let's pause on that first image, a veil.
How does a veil function as a mechanism of religion here?
A veil doesn't just block.
It filters.
It obscures the truth from those who would exploit or corrupt it, but it remains permeable to the genuine seeker.
It is a protective boundary.
Exactly.
It filters intent.
Second, he says true religion is a continuous rope extending from the heavens to the earth, continuous and without breakage.
Notice the contrast there.
The visiting scholar's system was a fragmented chain of human reports, full of missing links and contradictions.
The young teacher is describing an unbroken living connection between worlds.
Yes, a living connection.
Third, he says it is the firm handhold of those who adhere to the divine.
Fourth, it is the ark of the divine presence.
An ark, a sanctuary, a specific contained place of calm amidst the chaos of the contradictory market.
Absolutely.
Fifth, it is the ship of salvation, the vessel that carries those who climb aboard safely through waters in which all the rest drown.
Sixth, it is the light of the life, illuminating the path so one does not dwell in manifold darkness.
And finally, the 7th image, which beautifully returns us to the very beginning of their discourse, closing the loop, religion is the protected knowledge whose jewels have their distinctive signs.
The jewels with their distinctive signs.
This brings us right back to the forged glass under the assayers' lamps.
It does.
The signs are the internal criteria.
They are what allow the true assayers to tell the magnificent jewel from the polished glass.
True religion provides the mechanism for verification.
It is not just about holding a beautiful stone in the public sunlight and hoping the scholarly crowd agrees it has value.
It is about possessing the distinctive signs that prove its divine origin.
And the visiting scholar absorbs this entire sequence.
He hears the veil, the continuous rope, the firm handhold, the arc, the ship, the light, the protected knowledge.
And he accepts it.
He accepts this profound description as the essential meaning religion would have to have.
If there is a divine system designed to guide humanity, it must possess these qualities of protection, continuity, and clarity.
It cannot just be a paralyzing market of contradictory texts where you choose what you like.
Right.
But, and this is the crucial pivot for the rest of their journey.
He questions how to find the reality of which this description is merely the picture.
He accepts the theory of the seven images, but he needs the physical reality in the world.
And that hunger for the reality is exactly where the source material leaves us for this portion of the dialogue.
The way has been opened for the final part of their journey because the ground has been cleared.
Let us look at the terrain we have covered today.
We saw how relying solely on the public sunlight to verify spiritual jewels led to a fractured contradictory system.
We saw communities where feasts become fasts, where the profound living symbol of the moon reflecting the sun was lost to a physical administrative dispute over the horizon.
Yeah, and we saw the devastating practical consequences in the home where a man is left in
limbo, paralyzed by contradictory texts, unable to know the status of his own marriage.
But we also saw how intellectual charity and rigorous honesty allowed the visiting scholar to abandon a broken system.
He allowed the false equivalence between religion and his corrupted sharia to be fully dissolved.
He let go of his defense.
And by doing so, he made room in his mind for that magnificent 7-image description of what true religion must actually be.
All of which returns us to the unshaken
foundation the young teacher established from the very first moment they spoke.
A religion grounded only in transmitted reports is not religion.
Which leaves every one of us to consider our own foundations.
Think about the practices, the beliefs, the texts handed down to you through the generations.
Which jewel of inherited practice have you been holding in the sunlight without ever bringing it to the assayers?
And what would it cost you this week to take it there?